predicted this opening up over the last
three steps has
inevitably been accompanied by more
infection
and more hospitalization because
we must be clear that we cannot simply
eliminate
covid we must learn to live with it
and with every day that goes by we're
better protected
by the vaccines and we're better able to
live
with the disease vaccination greatly
reduces
transmission and two doses provide a
very high degree of
protection against serious illness and
death
but there are still millions of younger
adults who have not been vaccinated
and sadly a proportion of the elderly
and vulnerable
may still succumb even if they have had
two jabs and that's why we're so
concerned by the delta variant that is
now spreading faster
than the third wave that was predicted
in the february
road map we're seeing cases growing by
about
64 percent per week and in the worst
affected areas
it's doubling every week and the average
number of people being admitted to
hospital in england has increased by 50
week on week and by 61 in the northwest
which may be the shape of things to come
because we know
the remorseless logic of exponential
growth and even if the link
between infection and hospitalization
has been weakened
it hasn't been severed and even if the
link between
hospitalization and death
has also been weakened i'm afraid
numbers
in intensive care in icu are also
rising and so we've obviously faced a
very difficult choice we can
simply keep going with all of step four
on june
the 21st even though there is a real
possibility
that the virus will outrun the vaccines
and that thousands more
deaths would ensue that could otherwise
have been avoided or else
we can give the nhs a few more crucial
weeks to get
those remaining jabs into the arms of
those
who need them and since today i cannot
say that we have
met all our four tests for proceeding
with step four on june 21st i think it
is sensible
to wait just a little longer
by monday the 19th of july we will aim
to have double-jabbed around two-thirds
of the adult population including
everyone over 50 all the vulnerable
all frontline health and care workers
and everyone
over 40 who received their first dose by
mid-may
and to do this we will now accelerate
the second jabs for those over 40
just as we did for the vulnerable groups
so they get
the maximum protection as fast as
possible
and we will bring forward our target to
give every adult in this country
a first dose by the 19th of july
that is including young people over the
age of
18 with 23 and 24 year olds
invited to book jabs from tomorrow
so we reduce the risk of transmission
among the groups
that mix the most and
to give the nhs that extra time
we will hold off step four openings
until
july the 29th except for weddings
that can still go ahead with uh more
than 30 guests provide
provided social distancing remains in
place
and the same will apply to wakes
and we will continue to pilot events
such as
euro 2020 and some theatrical
performances
we will monitor the position every day
and if
after two weeks we have concluded that
the risk has diminished
then we reserve the possibility of
proceeding
to step four and a full opening sooner
as things stand and on the evidence
that i can see right now i'm confident
that we will not need
more than four weeks and we won't need
to go beyond july the 19th
it's unmistakably clear the vaccines
are working and the sheer scale
of the vaccine rollout has made our
position incomparably better
than in previous waves but now is the
time
to ease off the accelerator
because by being cautious now
we have the chance in the next four
weeks to save
many thousands of lives by vaccinating
millions more people and once the adults
of this company
have been overwhelmingly vaccinated
which is what we can achieve
in a short space of time we will be in a
far stronger position
to keep hospitalizations down to live
with this disease and to complete
our cautious but irreversible road map
to freedom thank you very much i'm not
going to hand over to chris
to do the slides thank you prime
minister first slide please
so the slides are arranged around the
four tests
which ministers said at the beginning of
the roadmap
the first test is that the vaccine
deployment program
continues successfully and i think
everybody in the country knows that both
first vaccinations and increasingly
rapidly second vaccinations are
progressing
very effectively thanks to the work of
the nhs volunteers and many
many others so this test has been met
and
we expect the rates to continue to be
good as the prime minister has laid out
next slide please the second
test was that evidence shows the
vaccines are sufficiently effective in
reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated and
we already have shown data that showed
that for previous variants
uh this was true we now have data and
some more has been released
by public health england today which
shows
uh data around the new delta variant
now what as has been talked about in the
press
for people who've got symptomatic
disease or you could get
symptomatic disease one dose of the
vaccine does provide
some protection but you do need two
doses
of the vaccine to provide a strong
degree of protection
uh but once you have two doses there is
somewhere between a 76 and 84 reduction
in symptomatic disease
next slide please the news is
even better for those for
the protection that these vaccines
provide for people against severe
disease and in terms of hospitalizations
the data so far uh real life life data
from here in the uk uh show that there
is a
very good reduction in hospitalizations
from the new
delta variant after both one and
two doses of the vaccines so after one
dose between a 57 and 85
reduction uh and after two doses uh
somewhere between 85 and 98 percent
reduction hospitalization so not
complete protection
but very substantial protection after
these again it reinforces the absolute
need
to get the second dose of the vaccine
so in terms of uh is this dose this
effective the data there are very
encouraging indeed next slide please and
if you see the effect of this
on people being hospitalized whereas
in the previous waves we had here in
the uk the great majority of those
hospitalized were older
over 65 uh citizens although there were
significant numbers of people under 65 i
think something
sometimes not appreciated and that's on
the left what we now have
is that the majority of those going into
hospital are
now from younger groups under 65 partly
because this is the group in which this
is spreading and it always starts off
spreading in the youngest groups
but largely uh we think because the
vaccines are providing a lot of
protection now for older citizens but it
is not complete and as you can see
even in those over 65 in which double
vaccination is already in place
there are still some hospitalizations
but the ratios
have completely reversed next slide
please
the third uh test is that infection
rates do not risk a surge in
hospitalizations which put unsustainable
pressure on the nhs
and the rates of hospitalizations at the
moment are
are low in all parts of the country but
and this is the important part on this
test what we are seeing
is a rapid rise particularly
marked where it was first really started
in the northwest of the country
uh but uh the the rest of the country is
following so there has been
a 64 increase since last week
and uh in terms of the north west and
you can see that in the dark blue color
here
and a 64 increase in england and that
rate will follow
uh we think where the north west has led
now these numbers are still relatively
small and if you're doubling from
50 to 100 100 to 200 the numbers are
still
relatively modest compared to the
capacity of the nhs but several doubling
times
uh relatively small number of doubling
times and you start getting to really
quite large numbers if you're doubling
up
uh from a thousand to two thousand or
two thousand to four thousand
over uh less than two weeks clearly uh
things can take off
very rapidly next slide please
and although um the the dark colors here
on this map
are where the rates of increase are
greatest but anywhere that is shaded
uh in yellow or uh orange
colors or dark brown uh rates are
increasing
uh where they're in green rates are
decreasing and you can now you can see
in this map
that the increase in the new variant
is occurring across the whole country
next slide please
the key question is what does this do to
hospitalizations and
as it's been uh said repeatedly and
rightly the
the link between people getting an
infection
and being hospitalized has been
substantially weakened a much
smaller proportion of those infected are
going into hospital
but it has not been completely stopped
and what you can see here is that in
terms of hospitalizations
again there has been a 61 increase
in hospitalizations since last week in
the northwest
and a 50 increase across the country as
a whole
but we expect that will probably
accelerate so there is
the the hospitalizations are following
but with a delay
uh the number of cases so although we do
not think an immediate
overwhelming of nhs is likely if this
continues on an exponential path
and in particular if that then
accelerated further
due to further loosenings then we would
run into trouble uh
in a relatively small number of doubling
times
next slide please so the final test
and really this has been led up to by
the things that have happened previously
is has our assessment of the risks been
fundamentally changed by new variants of
concern and what this slide shows is in
the orange
is the numbers uh uh in in of
uh cases of the b117
alpha variant that had been the one that
dominated
in the uk until very recently
and that has continued on a downward
path
uh and although it's probably stabilized
a bit in the last couple of
weeks nevertheless if this was the
variant we were primarily dealing with i
think it is very likely
that ministers would want to continue on
the current path the problem we have
is in the dark blue what you can see is
the delta variant
the new variant and that is whilst the
uh
the uh the b117 alpha is going down
the delta variant is going up and
currently going up exponentially and
just to make a point the
area in the gray shaded areas the data
are not complete those will carry on
going up
as data come in uh over the next weeks
so this is the reason why uh the the uh
assessment of risk has fundamentally
shifted
at the end of the um period that the uh
the prime minister is talking about we
will have a situation where a much
higher proportion
of the of people have been double
vaccinated or vaccinated
with coming out to school holidays we
all want to stress
that at that stage rates will be higher
than they are at the moment
but the next four weeks will reduce
significantly the risk of a very high
peak
which could cause significant problems
in terms of pressure on the nhs
and all the knock-on effects of that and
direct deaths from kovid
thank you very much thanks very much
chris uh patrick anything to add to that
at this stage okay fine thank you let's
go to members of the public for their
questions
andrew in worthing hello
uh well it was recently reported that
over 25s can now get the
first dose of their vaccine which means
that
12 weeks from now plus two weeks for the
vaccine to kick in
that'll take them to early september
when they're fully vaccinated
so my question is do you have any plans
to prioritize
university students so that they too are
fully vaccinated by the time they go off
to uni
uh thanks very much andrew well actually
what we're
we're saying today is i think that uh 23
and 24 year olds
uh will be able to uh to come forward
and get their
uh their vaccine uh doses as of uh as of
today
uh tomorrow um so we're we're going as
fast as we
as we can and um
by uh july the 19th
um uh two-thirds of
of adults aged
all adults in the country would have had
uh would have had two doses by the end
of
um of uh
by july the 19th uh we will have
uh all adults everybody over 18 would
have had
a first dose you're perfectly right
andrew that uh there will still be some
time to run before
um uh university students
who get vaccinated in july will get
there uh it will get their second dose
but uh we will certainly look at what we
can do to accelerate
uh second bases as we're doing now for
uh for people across the
across the country uh and you know if
there are outbreaks
uh in particular places as we've done uh
surge vaccination and surge testing we
may
uh do that uh in in those places as as
it may be necessary but
i wonder whether uh patrick or chris you
want to add anything to
that well one thing i would add pm is
just to remind people that the
the system in the uk has prioritized in
strict order those who are at highest
risk
all the way down uh down the uh down the
ratings and
for the great majority people of
university age other than those of
pre-existing health conditions
fortunately
they're at much lower risk than older
ages so we've gone down in age
ranges and that's the reason for the
ordering but as the prime minister says
we would expect that everybody of
university asia would have had at least
one
dose of vaccination by the start of next
term
thanks andrew tessa in bedfordshire
why can't testing and vaccination status
be used to open up weddings in the same
way as it's being used
as a twice postponed bride-to-be it
feels like wedding's the bottom of the
priority list despite being significant
life events without which some people
cannot progress with their lives
their lives well tess well tess i'm very
very sorry to hear about your
your wedding plans being postponed twice
and indeed i'm you know i'm
obviously i'm sorry for all the the
disappointment that's going to be
caused by uh going a bit slower as we
are
today what we are saying tess i don't
know if this is of any
practical consolation to you and i
really hope it is uh but we're saying
that
weddings can go ahead uh with more than
uh 30 people we're lifting that
restriction on 30 people from
uh from june the the 21st uh providing
social distancing
is observed uh i hope that uh works for
you
uh tessa and obviously i think you know
everybody will want to wish you every
uh possible you know good fortune with
your with your with your wedding but
uh all i can say is i'm sorry for the
disappointment that
uh this will certainly bring uh
to weddings to to many many businesses
uh but it's a few weeks
that i think is worth it to get those
get those jabs in uh
laura kunsberg of the bbc
thank you very much prime minister after
this four-week delay
do you expect life to return to
something that looks like normal so
people returning to the office
taking off face masks and ending the one
meter rule
and can you rule out extending this
delay any further
and could i ask professor woodsy or sir
patrick
when do you expect all adults to have
had
both jabs and after that would you start
vaccinating children i know there's been
a study into whether or not that's a
good idea
yeah thanks very much laura i think that
is the
the crucial question what what is the
world going to look like on on
july the 19th and i think i'd give it
this answer that
at a certain stage we're going to have
to learn to to live with the
the virus and uh to manage it as as
best we can and what we're trying to do
now
uh by this this delay is to reduce
the the current surge and we think we
can uh we can do that and we think that
a two week delay would
uh would make a substantial difference
in a four-week delay
uh we think would make even more of a
difference in reducing
the overall number of of deaths and
that's why we're uh that's why we're
doing it and
at the end of the that period of by by
july the 19th
uh we do think that we would have built
up a very considerable
wall of immunity around the whole of the
population
and at that stage laura on the basis of
the evidence
that i can see now i'm confident
that we will be able to go forward with
the full
uh step four the the full opening
that of course uh doesn't exclude the
possibility i'm afraid and we've got to
be
honest about this the possibility that
there is some uh
new variant that uh is far more
dangerous that
kills people in a way that we currently
cannot foresee
or understand that's obviously uh the
case but looking at the
the data now looking at the
effectiveness
of the vaccines against all
variants i think that we will be able to
deliver step 4 on on july the 19th
now at that stage people
may want to keep maintaining
social distancing they may want to keep
being sensible
but as far as i can see we will be in a
much better position as a country uh to
go forward with the full
uh open the ups that we uh we envisaged
but i mean chris and patrick well
on the on the vaccines i mean if you
take the the week of the 19th of july
all over 18's will be vaccinated or been
offered the vaccine
then eight to 12 weeks later then
everybody should have been
vaccinated in in that age group so
double vaccinated so
that's the sort of time scale and it's
worth really reiterating
that these vaccines are really highly
effective against the delta variant so
one of the concerns that we might have
had at the beginning was they weren't
going to work
as well well first there's not quite so
much but two dose is very effective
and by getting to both more people over
the age of 40 double vaccinated which
protects those
most likely to end up in hospital get
seriously ill
and giving all over 18s one dose
that will reduce spread because the
single dose will put up another barrier
to spread
amongst the age group most likely um to
spread because they have more social
contact so i think that's a sort of
double protection
uh that should be in place uh over the
next few weeks
and then on a question specifically on
children um
i i think as we've said several times
before the key thing
with children is safety we know that
the risks uh in terms of physical
disease to children other than some
people with
some children with significant
pre-existing problems
of physical health are much much lower
than for adults
so you wouldn't want to vaccinate unless
a vaccine is very safe and
vaccines are now being licensed in some
countries uh and we're accruing safety
data on the
on the safety of these vaccines in
children
and there are two possible reasons you
would want to vaccinate
children potentially but with caution
and this is the the point
i'm trying to stress the first would be
those groups who actually are at high
risk
of uh covid uh and i think jcvi will be
bringing forward advice on this
about which are the groups they think
are at particularly high risk of covid
and
those children specifically should be
vaccinated
to reduce the risk of them having severe
disease and in very
very very small number of cases but does
happen mortality
but the wider question is around also
the effect on children's particularly
education
and is the multiple disruptions that
might happen
uh have it going to have a very negative
impact on their life
chances including their the effect it
will have
on long-term risk of physical
and mental uh ill health and this is
going to be a a decision that will have
to be
based on the data we have available but
at the moment the big priority as the
prime minister has said is getting
through
all the adults down to 18 making sure
they're vaccinated and then double
vaccinated
thanks very much laura at carl dillon
itv news
thank you prime minister some of the
support that you currently have in place
for businesses
starts to reduce during this four-week
delay
why aren't you keeping support and
protections in place
at the level that they're at now and if
i could for professor witty
if we don't have this delay in the
easing of restrictions what does your
modeling
tell you could happen to
hospitalizations what's the worst that
could happen to the nhs
thanks very much uh carl the crucial
thing about what we're
agreeing to do today is uh to keep going
with the openings that we've got in
place so we're not
going backwards i don't think any of the
scientists have actually called for
uh a reversal and that's very important
it means that the businesses that are
currently
open and trading can continue uh to do
that uh
we're giving as you know all the support
measures that
uh have been uh put in place were
intended to
to last through to to september in terms
of uh of business rates uh
local authorities do have an extra
billion pounds to cover
uh to cover uh those who who need it
but i think the most important thing i
can say to those businesses who are
being asked to wait
uh another uh four weeks or you know
maybe as little as two weeks but let's
be realistic probably more likely
uh four weeks um i am confident that
we'll
get there and there's a difference
between um
the june the 21st date in the in the
july the 19th date in
at least in this sense the june the 21st
date was always a
a not before date uh i i do think that
looking at all the in other words we
weren't going to uh make take that step
before uh june the 21st but looking at
the
the data that i can see now looking at
the the scale of the vaccine
uh rollout i'm pretty confident that
july the 19th
will be as it were at a terminus date
and that
uh we'll be able to take things uh take
things forward from there
sorry chris the question in terms of
you addressed it to me the question
really on the model will be to patrick
but i will
just do a preamble on that to make two
points
um one of which is that whatever rate of
increase we're seeing now and would see
over the next few weeks
would be significantly increased if we
took the next step
because it means a lot of mixing of
households that are unrelated
indoors that fundamentally is what the
next step is about
so whatever rate it is will go faster if
and potentially quite significantly
faster were the next step taken over
this period
and the second thing is to reiterate
just to make sure everyone is aware that
we all agree on this
and not just on this panel but across
the whole of people who looked at this
is
no one thinks at the end of the four
week delay
the risk is gone there will still be
substantial numbers there will be
substantial numbers in hospitals
and sadly there will be some people who
will go on to die of this the question
is a matter of balance what are the
things
which is in sense reasonable to do
to eliminate avoidable uh mortality and
overwhelming of hospitals over the short
term
where if people died it's not just a
death delay it's actually
it's a death completely averted and what
are the things where actually at a
certain point you say probably we've
done most of the things
that we reasonably can given that we
will have to live with this virus which
will continue to cause severe infections
and kill people
for the rest of our lives where does the
balance lie yes patrick
well so as i said this is a virus that's
going to be with us
forever if you look back and look at the
increases we're seeing now in
hospitalizations
in people on ventilators if we didn't
have the vaccination we've got
we would be looking at a question of
is more lockdown needed that's not where
we are we're at a position now
where we're in a race against the virus
and the vaccines need to get ahead of it
and if you're in a race with somebody
you don't suddenly
assist them in putting the afterburners
on so they can out
and so that's really what we need to do
is to make sure we get the vaccines in
and as chris said the four-week delay
should reduce the peak whatever it would
be by something
between 30 and 50 percent so that's the
sort of gain
you get from the four weeks and actually
it's not very obvious that you get much
more gain from going on longer than that
at the moment so
it looks like quite a good length of
time you get the three advantages
over 18 single dose many more people
double dosed
and close to the school holidays with
the effect that that has to also take
the pressure off
and that should between them
significantly reduce the peak but there
will be an increase in numbers and there
will be an increase in hospitalizations
because that's what happens
when there's more mixing thanks very
much tom harwood
gb news
thank you prime minister um we've heard
a lot about how we want
this roadmap to be completely
irreversible
and that after four weeks hopefully all
those restrictions are gone
and don't come back but we also know
that in the winter
in the late autumn um these diseases can
spring up again pretty naturally they
can get pretty nasty
uh the health secretary has previously
spoken about a plan
for booster jabs in the autumn
and i was wondering when are we going to
get to see
that plan when can the media and the
scientific community
helpfully scrutinize and help out with
that plan
uh and when will those jabs be going
into people's arms
in the autumn to avoid these
restrictions ever coming back again and
then just one extra question
to the scientists given that we know
that this sort of nasty variant is
spreading
much more pervasively among young people
um is there are we considering at all uh
opening up again that excellent oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
to the under 40s well that's an
excellent question i'll leave the
uh uh chris and patrick to deal with but
on the
um uh the
irreversibility of the uh of the of the
road map and
you're quite right uh uh tom of course i
mean we're seeing a surge now as i said
earlier on uh we're seeing more
hospitalizations uh we're seeing
uh continued deaths although the numbers
are very very greatly
reduced and we must be realistic as as
we said at the beginning of the roadmap
and and throughout that people uh very
sadly will continue to lose their
their lives to to this disease so we
will have a a booster
program for for vaccines and uh we'll be
sending that out
uh very soon and uh you can expect the
health secretary
uh to to sell out uh how and when we'll
be we'll be doing that and which groups
can
uh will be coming forward first we'll
obviously the jcbi
uh will be studying that and uh
producing a
uh a timetable but the objective uh
is as i've said to to to be irreversible
to
to avoid um more lockdowns of the kind
that we've seen
uh and uh as things stand like i can't
see
a reason to do that there will as as
everybody has said
uh be further surges of the of the
disease
do you want to go on on uh on on astra
for underfoot astral for under 40s and
yeah i'll make a comment then chris will
want to build it
the balance is always the the risk
benefit in any drug or vaccine
and obviously the benefit is greater
in this particular case the higher the
level of virus so the risk benefit
changes all the time depending on where
you are
and these are decisions that are rightly
ones for jcvi to look at where the risk
benefit falls at any
point in in the pandemic and i think at
the moment the plan
is to get all of the um 18's and over
um vaccinated single dose with um with
um
other vaccines pfizer and moderna and
and that's uh
the target for the week of um july the
19th christian to answer that now and
the only point to make which is the
obvious one is the risk benefit of the
vaccines as currently
laid out is very strongly in favor of
vaccination
and we really would encourage everybody
to get their first job and get their
second
in terms of exactly which do uh which
vaccines as with exactly which drugs for
other bits of medicine
that may slightly change at the margins
and jc fire will continue to look at it
but at this point we're very clear that
this is a sensible approach which
actually maximizes the risk benefit
so the people get vaccinating be
confident that they are
increasing uh their chances of a very
healthy and good
outcome uh over over the next period i
mean it's worth saying that the vaccines
we've got
are spectacularly more effective than we
ever dared hope
i mean they really are very good that is
true thank you very much tom jason great
daily mail
uh thank you professor witty can i pick
you up on your
uh earlier answer are you as confident
as the prime minister that uh
july the 19th will be the end of this
matter we will be able to lift
restrictions then and
prime minister we've had an awful lot of
false dawns
uh over the last 18 months i hear what
you say about
a possible nasty new variant bombing the
emergence of one of those though can you
are you able to give us a sort of cast
iron guarantee that
uh this will be the last delay uh
providing nothing else turns up and
and finally what would you say to andrew
lloyd webber who
says that you're bankrupting a sort of
critical and irreplaceable
industry there's plenty of other people
in his position too
do they factor at all in your
calculations when making decisions like
this
thanks jason look of course they do and
uh i've got to colossal admiration for
andrew lloyd webber the entire theater
sector is one of the great glories of
this
of this country and you know it's it's
broken everybody's heart
to see what we've had to to go through
and i i bitterly
uh regret the the fact that we you know
we must be cautious
again now uh and actually on
on cinderella and and and uh
uh uh lord production i think we're in
talks to
with him to try to uh make it work and
we'll do whatever we
can to be helpful as i said earlier on
there are some uh some pilot events that
we hope will be able to
to go ahead even in the next four weeks
and as for your question about you know
can i give a cast iron
guarantee uh that uh there won't be
further
delay uh on the basis of what uh we can
currently
see well all i can say is on the basis
of what we can currently see i am
confident that as i said
uh july 19th will be a a terminal date
not a
not a not before date uh but you know
that is on the basis of the evidence
currently before us
we have reasons uh to be confident
looking at the scale of the vaccine
rollout looking at the
as patrick was saying looking at the
levels of product protection
they give and in terms of your question
to me actually
i completely agree with the prime
minister's answer and i'm sure sir
patrick wood as well
thank you thanks very very much uh
jim picker financial times
prime minister one area of major public
confusion at the moment is what to do
about summer holidays whether to take
them abroad
grant chaps the transport secretary has
said people don't have long
to wait for their summer breaks abroad
other ministers such as george eustis
the environment secretary have
encouraged people to stay at home which
of these contradictory pieces of advice
would you recommend and on a sort of
related question it is
increasingly clear that many industries
will still be struggling by the end of
the summer such as aviation
and hospitality is there any situation
in which you can see
the furlough scheme and other major
business support schemes continuing
beyond their current end date the cliff
edge at the end of september
jim thanks very much well it follows
from what we've all been saying
about july the 19th uh that
things you know could uh still change
uh very much and i think probably will
change uh very much for the
uh for the better in this country in the
sense that i think we will see a
a substantial opening up uh even more
open
than we currently are for uh a lot of
the summer
uh on travel abroad i think that the
the most important thing is just to
follow the the red amber uh
green guidance that we're giving that's
continually reviewed and that's the
that's the important thing i wouldn't
want to give any more
uh guidance the the than that at this
stage uh
jim uh and so i can't remember what your
last question what was your second
question
for struggling industries sorry
forgiveness absolutely
uh on furlough um
we always made sure that the
the furlough scheme uh would continue
until uh september
uh to take account of the the whole
spread of the
uh of the roadmap uh chancellor was uh
has always been very very clear about
that
uh we don't think that there will be on
the basis of what we can see now
jim in the in the data on the basis of
uh
the vaccine effectiveness that we can
see now
uh we don't think that we'll need to
change that
thanks very much uh joe murphy of the of
the evening standard
thank you very much prime minister and
thanks uh gentlemen for
answering our questions again um
so patrick you said the vaccines are
spectacularly good
and a lot of people argue that all we
need to do now is to
let infections rise and that'll be okay
if hospitalization and deaths don't
increase
based on what you know so far would you
be relaxed if infections went
back to january levels how high would
they have to go before you called
the prime minister and said look maybe
it is time to slow things down again
um professor witty london's vaccination
rates are a long way below
all the other regions and nations only
36
have had the second doses according to
the
dashboard um how worried are you about
this
and what will you do to improve the
situation especially
will you agree to measure speed up the
type of vaccines for london
that young people can have and prime
minister
july the 19th is going to be held as the
new freedom day
do you see it as the date when
everything will be eased including those
tough nuts
like nightclubs being allowed to reopen
and we can all
dispense with masks and social
distancing for good
right well we were given questions in
order so i think it was
battery first well i think the um
vaccines
are very very effective but of course if
you have a massive wave of infection
the vaccines aren't 100 effective and
you will see people
in hospital and a large proportion of
those will be double vaccinated
and some of those unfortunately will die
so they will not 100
protective and therefore avoiding a very
very large
peak is important that's why
the second part of the vaccination which
is
stopping or reducing the chance of
spreading is an important part of this
and that's why getting the younger
people vaccinated becomes important
because you stop the size
of the increase in any peak
and hopefully manage that down to a
level where the number of infections
is reduced and of course the proportion
of people who then get
severely ill hospitalized from that is
reduced even further by the vaccination
so that has to be the aim
and um realistically if we ever got a
very very large wave
there would be a very large number of
people in hospital but the the plan
and the vaccination program is designed
precisely to stop that from occurring
uh on on london i mean i think let's
start off with the glass half full
uh london uh londoners as in the rest of
the uk have shown great enthusiasm for
vaccination
uh overall the rates are higher than
many countries
uh would really dream of having at this
point in time but
they are behind uh by around in some
areas 10 percent
uh other parts of the country so they're
high and i think we shouldn't
pretend that they're low they're high
but they should be even higher
uh and it is uh you know some of this is
mechanistic
it's because there's a lot more people
move around in london uh records and so
on are less uh clear-cut there's a
number of reasons why
uh london in common with other uh major
cities uh in the uk
uh always tends to have slightly lower
rates of vaccination and uh screening
and many other
uh medical interventions of this sort
but uh you are completely right that
what we need to do is concentrate on
these areas where the rates are lower
because we want to get all of them right
up to the very highest rates which is
what
provides protections for individuals and
by being vaccinated someone provides
protection
for those around them so you are you are
completely right we do need
to concentrate on them and look in the
different particular bits of london
because london is
a very varied city and find the areas
with the lowest rates and really push to
get them up
uh whatever the reasons are yeah
thank you very much um chris look i i
joe i am concerned also actually about
about london uh
of course it's absolutely correct as
chris says a huge number of
londoners have come forward it could be
very proud of what they're doing but i
think it'd be great if we could get
those
uh those rates up uh even higher and
on on your point about you know opening
up everything on
july the 19th i'm acutely conscious that
you know it's not just that you know
nightclubs and
and i can't go ahead and the theater
industry and many other parts of
sectors are still not able to uh to open
fully
there are many businesses that need to
move beyond social distancing
um many jobs uh where we need to
be able to to do things uh in the way
that we always used to
to do them and people are yearning to
get back to that
as indeed uh as i am and so i'm
determined
uh to be able to do that by july the
the 19th uh at the moment i am confident
on the basis of what we can see on the
basis of the
effectiveness of the of the vaccines the
the rollout that we can
do i'm confident that we'll be you know
barring unforeseen
unforeseeable uh
new variants and so on i'm confident
that we will
get there but uh you in this
game fighting this virus you you've got
to learn to be
to be cautious we want a road map
that is irreversible and to achieve
an irreversible road map you have to be
you have to be cautious and
uh the objective of this of this short
delay is to use these valuable uh these
crucial
weeks to to save thousands
of lives of lives that would otherwise
be lost i'm afraid by vaccinating
millions more people as fast as we can
and that's what we're
we're going to do and that's the the
announcement tonight thank you all very
much
there we are boris johnson the prime
minister announcing a four-week delay to
reopening
uh completely opening up thus far he
said
had led to more infections and we're
concerned about the delta
variant which in some areas he said is
doubling
every week there is a remorseless logic
to
exponential growth he said in numbers in
hospital and in icus are rising if we
open up it could lead to thousands more
deaths so it makes sense
to hold off and vaccinate more people
and younger people and give the nhs more
time so four weeks
delay as expected but he did say
if after two weeks things look better uh
they as he put it reserve the right to
open up earlier
but he uh said uh july the 19th
is the terminus date and then chris
witte spoke of the effectiveness of
vaccines this was the good news
against hospitalization from the delta
variant after two
doses let's bring in uh
political editor beth rigby who was uh
listening to all that so beth what did
you make of it
well it was as expected really mark
there the prime minister confirming that
there will be
a four week delay uh to unlock into that
final
phase but he started off saying he was
confident that he would
be able to ease restrictions on that
date and then he went
further and harder in that press
conference saying that he expected it to
be
the terminus date and that was backed up
by the scientists there both talking
about the effectiveness
of the vaccine and what are they really
doing here they're buying time you
heard patrick valance there he said
basically if we do this so let me just
get what my notes here
he said a four week delay will reduce
the peak by
30 to 50 percent of this current wave
and he said it also did three other
things it would give
more protection for over 40s because
they would all be offered
two doses by july the 19th it would give
some protection
for over eight teens as they all get
offered one jab
and it would be near the school holidays
so there's a natural break where all the
kids
break up for a few weeks and then that
gives the government another few weeks
to vaccinate more people
hey beth thank